كل وفد بيرجع لبلده وان مافيش تفاوض
ومافيش اي اجراءات في اتجاه تفاوض في
المرحله
[موسيقى]
الحاليه اهم اللي حصل في الغرف المغلقه هو
رفع السقف التفاوضي يمكن في الاجتماع
الاول ابتدت الارقام تختلف عن اللي كنا
انتهينا عليها في المسارات السابقه صياغات
نفسها تختلف ابتدت يتم طرح موضوعات خارج
اطار التفاوض يعني احنا
بنتفائل سد وحيد اسمه سد النهضه نحن لا
نتحدث ولا نتفاوض على مشروعات مستقبليه
وتنميه مستقبليه وحاجات الحقيقه تم الزج
بيها في الغرف المغ علاقه غير مقبوله
بالنسبه للجانب المصري تم تقليل الارقام
اللي بتامن الامن المائي المصري في حالات
الجفاف كمان كان في ذج ببعض النصوص المقطه
التي لا تعني الكثير وما تديش الحقيقه
الهدف اللي مطلوب من النصوص دي استخدام
صياغات مناطه زي ما بقول لحضرتك وصياغات
غير
[موسيقى]
ملزمه
he
[موسيقى]
ع سنين بنفاوض حدث فيهم الملق الاول
والثاني والثالث والرابع فماذا ننتظر يعني
ماذا ننتظر ان ينتهي الملء ونقعد نتفاوض
على الملء وهو انتهى فبالتالي ده تكريس
لامر واقع على الارض ومن مصلحه اثيوبيا ان
يستمر التفاوض الى ما لا
نهايه